tu sais que tu vas être mrs.
marteau noir as-tu dit à mon frère Wow
qu'est-ce que ce petit clown sort avec ma
sœur oh mec Schtroumpf je voulais ta
bénédiction et demander à ta sœur de se marier
montre-moi que tu es digne d'elle je ne suis pas
censé faire ça je vais t'emmener
sur le trajet aujourd'hui est votre
jour de formation tous les nouveaux concessionnaires à Atlanta sont
approvisionnés par Antonio Pope à
Miami vous devez me trouver quelque chose sur
ce gars deux jours en haut désolé mais les
adultes parlent Ben vous êtes à
peine un  officier probatoire Oh James si
tu veux l'emmener à Miami tu peux alors
réunir une équipe et réparer ça Miami
James je vais tu ferais mieux de te préparer
viens ici mec d'accord non c'est trop tôt
ton partenaire épouse ta soeur
bon sexe de flic  le flic courney est le meilleur
organisateur de mariage à atlanta donc ce que
tu vas faire ne te laisse pas intimider
ce que tu vas faire
la contrebande à travers le
port que vous êtes g  onna m'aider à obtenir des
preuves tangibles sur lui pense que je vais abandonner
mon nom tu ne l'abandonnes pas est-il
t'honorer Tasha parce que non seulement mettre
son prénom de téléphone je suis tombé sur
s'il vous plaît appelez-le les goules l'appelant c'est
quoi elle  sonnerie oh tu regardes oh
ouais peut-être que tu dis les meilleurs coups alors j'ai
joué ta sonnerie ça ne coûte absolument
rien depuis que tu es là
voiture piégée ouais mais nous
avons fait les autres trucs
ton partenaire James nous nous protégeons
oh nous sommes devenus maladroits est-ce que tu chantes le sien
bien sûr je t'aime va le reposer encore une
fois
mes nerfs sont mauvais jour oh mon dieu sa
tête de zombie a tiré quelle [ __ ] oh  Merci